we're ready
well this is my first time interviewing
someone else I'm very excited some of
these questions I've may have written
before I saw the movie so the movies
called Eddie the Eagle and now you play
Eddie
no no no no you just see it right man oh
no I did yeah yeah I mean that's yeah
come on right many actors enjoy
performing their own stunts yes do you
do all your own acting if there's sex
scenes I'd do them yes that's where the
craft is yeah it's not key to a good
marriage did you guys get any notes from
the studio too so Eddie's mouth shut
make lasers shoot from his eyes you know
I didn't but I thought it'd be a great
idea
as a story it totally makes sense part
of a staff always understand do you ever
age not since 2009 yeah gorgeous you're
a two-time Tony winner
you're an Oscar nominated actor how much
acute Jackman's immense success is raw
talent hmm and how much is just
advantageous bone structure thank you
for coming from sexiest man alive 2012
10 so we in tan yeah we're the old model
I'm gonna open this up to a few fan
questions here that I got first one
comes from Brian Glen olds from
Vancouver British Columbia that's
festive
I love Latin America that's amazing
Brian asks Hugh I heard that on x-men
Wolverine hmm you had specially designed
lifts put in your shoes so you would
appear taller than one of your co-stars
is this true or just a silly fact it's
it's true I I did next question but but
it was a story reason that everything in
that movie was about story in character
starting advancing it you know yeah
my next question here is from from a
Blake Lively from New York City New York
he writes Hugh I tried calling you on
the burner phone and you didn't answer
are we still meeting at the Gansevoort
hotel this afternoon I don't have much
time because Ryan's having a mani-pedi
from 3:00 to 4:00 yeah I'm having a
mani-pedi from 3:00 to 4:00
you're gonna yeah it's super weird
now this movie is about flying high yeah
tell me the last time you experiment
with drugs which one was I do you have
any right now no no no I'd love this
just a little bit of scene work and I'd
love to just pick up a few pointers if
you're okay sure I would love you to do
is take this knife hold this okay all
right yeah okay and I'm gonna say
something okay hold on it's all right oh
my god he's gonna Knight you know you
say yeah yeah that's not a knife now
that's enough come on oh thank you very
much Hugh Jackman my pleasure I honestly
that was my favorite interview I've ever
given Thank You Ryan Reynolds is the
only one you've ever given it is and it
will be the latter confident Olympus
invent a ski season for the common Unger
I can appeal you can